welcome to the show.
Hope everybody had a good weekend.
My weekend was notable audibly
free of social media.
I'll follow up about that.
A topic of a stunningly high interest, actually
when I mentioned it last week, I'll follow
up about that later in the show.
Uh, but let's get right into what's going
on and what happened over the weekend when
we have been having these conversations about
the movement to impeach Donald Trump.
We will, Annette have inevitably sort of get
to a point where someone will say, Republicans
aren't going to participate.
Republicans won't impeach Trump no matter
what Trump says, no matter what Trump does.
And that's true.
I mean whatever happens, Republicans are going
to be an impediment to Donald Trump's impeachment
if it is ever going to get going.
And that's not really the focus of what I
want to talk about today.
What I want to focus in on is how that statement
can be misunderstood, that claim Republicans
will be an impediment, could easily be misunderstood
as what Nixon did was worse than what Trump
did.
So the reason that Republicans in 74, we're
ready to sign on to Richard Nixon's impeachment,
which of course was what precipitated his
resignation.
And Republicans now are not willing to sign
on to Donald Trump's impeachment.
The difference might be misinterpreted as
Trump just hasn't done stuff that's worthy
of impeachment, whereas Richard Nixon did.
But we've already widely debunked that notion.
We actually looked at the three, um, I guess
call them transgressions that were part of
the, uh, articles of impeachment against Richard
Nixon.
And we found that between the molar report
and all sorts of other evidence, it all points
to Donald Trump having committed all three
of the same transgressions.
And remember that these are a number one obstruction
of the investigation into a DNC headquarters
being broken into.
This is Richard Nixon's articles of impeachment
violating constitutional rights of citizens
and impairing the administration of Justice
and failing to produce papers and things as
directed by duly authorized subpoenas from
Congress without rehashing the entire list
item by item.
Because we did it last week.
I don't want to repeat the same story.
Trump has done all three of those same things
that were in the articles of impeachment against
Richard Nixon.
The difference between Nixon 1974 and Trump
2019 is not the act.
It's the Republicans that are currently in
elected office.
There's a really good article by Richard Wolf
and not wolf.
The Economist who was my professor at Umass
when I was an Undergrad.
Uh, Richard Wolff, an e on the end, the British
a journalist, he has a great article about
this in the Guardian, which were linking to
from our youtube clip.
Uh, for this story.
Today's Republicans would not have impeached
Richard Nixon either.
And that's really what sort of at the crux
of the status quo in which we find ourselves.
If Richard Nixon had today's Republicans,
and if he also had Fox News, which would be
a pretty big help, Nixon would not have had
to resign because Republicans wouldn't have
been about to sign on to impeachment Nixon
also.
So not only did Nixon not have today's Republicans,
not only did Nixon not have Fox News and the
right wing Echo Chamber of Cable News and
Talk Radio, Nixon also didn't have a William
Barr, a professional at covering up presidential
misdeeds.
And I'll even go a step further.
We're on the cusp of finding out even more
transgressions committed by Donald Trump.
Remember this stunning moment from the bar
testimony last week were Senator Kamala Harris
asked a very simple question, has Trump directed
you mister attorney general to investigate
specific people?
And William Barr was reduced to sort of a
stuttering, bubbling buffoons asking for the
question to be repeated and ultimately saying,
I just don't know.
Thank you mister chairman.
Uh, attorney general bar.
Has the president or anyone at the White House
ever asked or suggested that you open an investigation
of anyone?
Um, I wouldn't, I wouldn't, uh, yes or no.
Could you repeat that question?
I will repeat it.
Yeah.
Has the president or anyone at the White House
ever asked or suggested that you open an investigation
of anyone yes or no?
Please, sir.
MMM.
The president or anybody else seems you would
remember something like that and be able to
tell us.
Yeah, but I'm, I'm trying to grapple with
the word suggest.
I mean, there had been discussions of, of
matters out there that, uh, they have not
asked me to open a investigation, but I have
safe suggested.
I didn't know.
I wouldn't say suggests did
I dunno.
Inferred.
You don't know.
Okay.
In the 1970s, absolutely disgusting and brazen
abuses of power actually kinda crossed party
lines.
Lawmakers on both sides said, we're Republicans.
They're Democrats or were Democrats and they're
Republicans.
But abuses of power at this level.
Cross partisanship.
It's a red line of sorts, so to speak.
Bad luck for Nixon.
But Trump is in a very different environment
and this is actually something that the people
around Trump have crafted really, really well.
Trump's propagandists, whether it's Stephen
Bannon early on, Stephen Miller, Roger Ailes
when he was around, right?
Whoever was advising Trump about how to deal
with the Mueller probe from the beginning.
They realized, and this is, I'm not criticizing
them for this.
I mean this is their team and they ran this
really well.
They realize that in the 1970s Nixon didn't
have the support of the court of public opinion
and everything came from that.
Okay, so what the people around Trump focused
on is, let's make sure the Fox News Echo Chamber
is with us.
Let's make sure we have someone in the Justice
Department who can manage this from a public
relations perspective.
They installed William Barr as long as the
court of public opinion supports Trump, which
means his base gives enough cover to Republicans
were Republicans don't have to say, damn I,
I kind of need to hold the guy accountable
or I'm in jeopardy for my own reelection.
It gives Republicans the cover to insist that
this is a witch hunt, that its presidential
harassment, whatever term you want to apply
to it, and this is what you have.
You can make the case that Republicans are
immoral when it comes to this, and I wouldn't
disagree with you, but the most important
thing when the rubber meets the road is that
they are a moral, they are a moral in that.
It's just about what can we get away with
for our own personal self preservation.
They would not have impeached Richard Nixon
and that's the real difference.
Not that Trump and Nixon are so drastically
different in terms of their wrong doing.
In fact, there are some really good smart
legal analysis which say sort of political
legal analysis which say that actually there's
way more evidence against Donald Trump and
there is a, then there was against Richard
Nixon for similar types of misdeeds.
As I told you from the three articles of impeachment
against Richard Nixon.
The difference is the Republican, the Republican
Party and of course the sort of media environment
surrounding that.
Tell me I'm wrong.
I'm ready to have my mind change.
Would today's Republicans have impeached Richard
Nixon?
I think the answer is very clearly now